hi everyone I'm really happy to open the
machine learning track today and during
the next 30 minutes I'll talk about
experiment tracking and how to do it
with G so first a bit about a bit about
myself my name is Eric and I work as a
data science at ball which is the
largest e-commerce platform in the
Netherlands outside of my work I also
write articles about data science this
actually led me to publishing two
editions of my book and in my spare time
I like to read and play video
games so we have a few things planned
for today we'll start with the reason
why we should track our machine learning
experiments then I will tell tell you
why I think DBC is a good solution for
this problem and how it actually works
and we will wrap it up with a live demo
during which I will run a few
experiments as we know building a
machine learning product is a highly
iterative process before finding a good
solution to our problem we might try out
tens or maybe hundreds of
approaches and even pushing the deploy
button does not mean that our work is
over most likely we will continue
running experiments to try to improve
improve the performance of our
model and as data scientists I think we
know how to come up with lots of cool
ideas for experiments we might be
inspired by a blog post we read in the
morning or maybe the latest research
paper we've seen on
Twitter and then we'd like to run some
experiments really
quickly however that often comes at the
price of
reproducibility and this because in
order to iterate fast we have tendency
to C cut some corners
instead of doing that we should try to
make sure that those two are not
mutually
exclusive so at some point of your
career you might have heard a similar
story your colleague tells you that some
time ago which knowing our like is a
long time our team run a very successful
experiment with a much better score than
the current model we are asked to find
out what we did differently back then
and ideally can we do that before the
end of the week so the story can also
have some further modifications like for
starters the colleague that worked on
the problem might have already left the
company or we might have entirely
changed our approach to the problem to
or three times since then and my
personal favorite the CSV file that we
are using as input from the business was
updated meaning overwritten dozen times
and of course you do not have previous
versions of the file so I hope that
after hearing stories like that we are
all determined to keep up uh keep our
experiments fully
reproducible
so the first solution to this problem
might be an ulle
one you can simply track our experiments
on sticky notes or in a physical
notebook clearly that's not a very
scalable solution and once the stickers
go to the bin we can't really recover
them
anymore so another approach would be to
use the good old spreadsheet there we
can track quite a lot of things we can
filter the rows or maybe sort the
observations by the
score but while this is already better
than the stickies we are still missing a
few things in our looks for example code
a code version or model version or maybe
a few more error
metrics you might say that this is a
simple problem well as we are already in
a spreadsheet we can simply add more
columns and you're fully right however
this quickly becomes hard to
manage and it is very error prone and I
don't think I have to convince you that
logging those last two experiments on
Friday at quarter to 5 is probably not
close to the top of the things that you
want to do so given those ideas do not
work that well you're probably thinking
that there must be an already
established ideally out ofab box
solution for this and indeed that's the
case so it turns out that there is quite
a lot of these Solutions available out
there and I have probably missed quite a
few of those here so the question
becomes now which one to
choose this might be a tough decision
because we need to consider pros and
cons of all of them for example the
vendor locking problem ease of
Maintenance Associated cost
or security so for example we might not
want to send our data or metrics to any
external services or
databases so today I want to show you
why I think DBC is a good solution for
tracking our
experiments first of all I really hope
that you're already tracking your code
with Git and DBC is an open source tool
that builds on top of git so to work
with DBC we do not need a dedicated
metric server in terms of storage it
works with all major providers so aw s
gcp Azure or even Google
Drive DBC is basically a common line
tool and the commands are very similar
to the ones from git and what is even
better is that there is a dedicated vs
code extension so we can do all of those
things with a few clicks in a friendly
UI and lastly DBC is actually very
flexible and super easy to start with so
we can start prototyping and tracking
our experiment in a matter of
minutes so the basic approach to running
a reproducible experiment Pipeline with
this setup would be that we track the uh
track our code with
Git and all the other things present in
the data science workflow with DBC so
this includes hyperparameters metrics
data machine learning models and any
other artifacts that we might want to
try so now how now that we know that we
can use DVC for reprod reproducible
experimentation how does that actually
work to understand the entire workflow
we need to focus on fre elements we'll
start with versioning data and
artifacts then we will discuss the
pipelines which help with making sure
that all the steps of our experiments
are fully
reproducible lastly I will show how
running experiments Works in
practice to understand how data
versioning work Works let's assume that
we have an already existing project in
our machine in that project we have a
script training a model using two CSV
files
and by the way all the principles we
discuss here regarding these files they
also apply to any other artifacts we
might want to track with
DVC as you probably already have guessed
we do not want to track those files with
Git so that's why we initialize a DVC
project in our directory this creates a
local cash on our
machine and once we start tracking the
data directory of DBC the data files in
our project will be ignored and git will
track the new file
instead the new file is called Data DVC
in this case and it's a placeholder or a
pointer to the actual data's location in
the DVC cach so as you can see to create
a pointer DBC uses a hashing function in
this case it's
md5 and this as the new file is a small
text file it can be easily version web
gate while the actual data will be
stored somewhere else and under the
hoood DVC will make the connection
between the files metadata and its
actual
location as I mentioned we can use the
pointer file to find the actual data
files in the local DVC cach so so far so
good let's create a new experiment right
now so for example let's assume that we
received a new CSV file from our
stakeholders which we should use instead
of the first CSV file in our project we
simply replace the file then we tell DVC
hey the data in the directory we are
tracking has changed and the pointer
file needs to be
updated so a new hash is generated and
it once again points to the cach here we
can already see a very useful capability
of DVC it does not duplicate files
unnecessarily so the second data file
that is common in both experiments is
stored only once as it has not actually
changed so this might seem as not that
significant but let's imagine a case
with 100,000 images and that we manually
edit maybe 10 of those in such a case we
definitely do not want to fully
duplicate the entire data set to track
these 10 extra
images so that's almost it we already
know how the tracking happens so far the
cach is located locally on our machine
that's great for quick experimentation
and
prototyping but at some point we might
want to actually store some of the
versions of our data or maybe the entire
project the more persistent place for
example somewhere where we it can be
also accessed by other team
members as such we can also have a
remote storage and push the data files
there as I have mentioned already this
can be in can be any of the cloud
providers a private server or even local
directory if we want it to
be so we already know how tracking works
and the next key component is the DVC
pipeline the pipelines make sure that
the entire experiment is fully
reproducible including code parameters
data models and so on so as you can see
we have defined three stages in a yaml
file and again this yaml file is a text
file so it can be easily versioned with
g
breaking it down a bit our pipeline
actually consists of three steps
preparing data training a model and
evaluating its
performance each step is essentially a
python script a separate python
script in the PIP plan We additionally
provide each step's dependencies and its
outputs as you can see the output of
some of the steps is directly used by
the next
steps and the outputs of all the
intermediate steps are versioned with
DVC again any small text file any small
text files are version gate while other
artifacts are tracked to
DVC so now that we know how tracking
actually works and how we can use the
pipelines we are getting close to the
demo part so as a data scientist and the
gamer I always wanted to play around
with a Pokemon data set so I'm really
glad that I finally had the opportunity
to do that and for those who are not
familiar with Pokemon it's a series of
video games in those games you basically
create catch creatures called Pokemon
train them and battle other trainers to
become the very best as you can see
there's a lot of different species of
Pokemon and the image does not even
cover all of them so right now we have
around 1,00 unique Pokemon in
total so the task for today will be to
classify each Pokémon as a leg Legendary
Pokémon or a normal one in Short
legendary po Pokemon are the rare and
strong ones that you might get a single
chance to battle in a game so and to
classify them we'll use their stats such
as attack defense or hit
points and for the case of the demo DVC
is already set up in this project but
there are links to tutorials on how to
do that at the end of the
presentation I will switch to V code
right
now and here I will show you all the
files that I have already mentioned
during the presentation so we start with
the parameters file where we store the
parameters for each of the stages of the
pipeline so in this case we have two
well we store parameters for two stages
preparing data and also the training
part here for example for data we
include the test size or maybe if we
want to include mega evolutions of
Pokemon or not for training some
parameters of machine learning
models then we have the DVC pipeline
that I have already
mentioned in general DBC is a command
line tool so there are multiple ways we
can create the DVC pipeline we can
either do it using the command line or
we can also just manually type in the
contents of the in an text file in this
case I went for typing it manually and
you can see that we have the three steps
that I already described during the
presentation so preparing data training
a machine learning model and evaluating
its performance for each of the steps I
specify what is the script which is what
is the python script that is used to run
it what are the dependencies what are
the outputs and also um if there are any
other things that are cons that need to
be considered so for example the
parameters and one thing to note here
that I haven't mentioned before is the
metrics at the end so by default DVC
tracks metric. Json file which is uh an
output containing the metric of our
model and that's it tracks it the same
way as it automatically tracks the
parameters file but we there are also
different ways to add a bit more custom
metrics to the uh for DC to track and I
will show those in a
second so I will quickly go through all
the steps of the par
of the pipeline but again this is a very
simple project so you will see that
there's nothing fancy here it's just
loading a few steps training a model and
outputting the performance so for the
prepare data set I just load the
parameters from the parameter file I
read the CSV file do some basic
filtering based on the parameters and
well create the train test split also
based on the parameter and uh store
those into the process uh that process
data
directory in the train step I basically
again load the parameters load the
process data set create instantiate a
light GBM classifier using the
parameters from the parm file train it
and output the model in the models
directory one thing to note here is the
extra step uh of DVC life so DBC live is
a helper Library which works as a
machine learning logger so I mentioned
that DV automatically tries the metrix
file as the output of the metrix but we
can also log a lot of different things
out uh ourselves so in this case I'm
using a DVC live call so the DBC live is
integrated with quite a lot of different
machine learning Frameworks and in this
case it's by GBM but it's it also works
P caras and any other uh libraries out
there so in this case what it will do is
it will track the uh evaluation loss
over the training
steps and then additionally I also store
and track a feature importance plot in
the form of a static
image last step is the evaluation step
in which I again load the model load the
process data set create predictions and
again using DVC live I store quite a lot
of different things so I store a
confusion Matrix an R curve and a
Precision vle curve and I also store the
metrix that I mentioned before in a
metrix Json file so that's basically all
the files that are here as you can see
is quite a simple workflow just to give
an example how it works now I will show
a few ways how to run the experiments so
the simplest way to run an experiment in
DVC is to go to the parameters the am
file change one of the parameters so
let's say Max def to1 save the file and
in the command line run DBC experiment
run so as you can see the experiment
will start running
and one very interesting thing to note
here is that it says uh stage prepare
data didn't change skipping what it
actually means is that there is smart
caching under the hood for all the
pipeline steps so if we trigger the
entire Pipeline and maybe two out of
three steps have not changed at all
since the last run and this includes any
of the inputs parameters or code DBC
will simply skip those and pick up the
outputs from the cach this way it just
works faster if we for example have a
costly training stage that we do not
actually want to run so the experiment
finished we can Now quickly look at some
results so if we as I mentioned DVC is a
common line tool so if we run DBC X
show we will see a table and here we see
free free things so the workspace which
is basically our current directory the
main which is the branch and also an
experiment if I now um go go over the
table you can see that it tracks quite a
lot of things but I will explain those
slightly in a slightly different way
that will maybe be a bit more
interactive so for now I will exit this
and yeah we can run experiments in many
different ways I already showed you that
one I think simplest one another one is
we can manually type in the command so
BBC experiment R use the set parameters
flag to actually indicate which
parameter we want to change
and let's say we want to change a train
parameters and Max Dev to I don't know
17 okay there is of course a typo here
so it is set
form I hope this will
work so as you can see the value in the
parameter caml file was updated
automatically and DVC is running another
experiment now without any from my my
myself in the meantime another way of
running experiments is to use the vs
code command so we can use the DVC
command modify workspace parameters and
run and then we have an interactive tool
which we can use to select which
parameters we want to change so let's
say that for the case of sake of this
experiment I will pick the Mega
Evolutions modify this one it was false
I will include those in our data
set so basically what you see is that
this is an interactive way of WR writing
the command line command
automatically so now that the experiment
is running I already hinted that there
is a DBC vs code extension which makes
our life much easier so let's go
there and let's start with the
experiments so experiments is basically
a table that I already showed you in
command line but but displayed in a much
more interactive way so we have three
elements here with the git icon and
those are basically the commits to the
git uh git repository you also see those
experiments here Urban jump extra Vega
and some other ones those are the
experiments i r just now what is
important to notice is that those
experiments they are not git commits so
DBC under the hood uses git references I
will not go into much detail what those
are but I will link to an article
explaining that so with those git
references we can run hundreds or
thousands of
experiments without actually committing
all of those different branches to our G
repository this way we are skipping
cling and well we can only promote
whichever experiment we want to an
actual G comit so in this case let's see
what we have here so we can see that in
the in the source uh Source area we are
tracking three different Python scripts
the evaluate script changed a bit in
between runs we can also see the models
of course the model was trained each
time with different parameters so we can
see there are different versions of
those models the process data change for
the latest experiment only and that
makes sense because I changed the Mega
Evolutions file in the prepare data step
which means that basically another uh
data set is created which is slightly
larger and we have then all the
parameters that we use for the models
the metrics that we store so their
performance and also the metrics
calculated during the training step with
DBC live so this of course is fully
interactive so let's say that I don't
really care about raw data because I
know that it will not change I can hide
it or maybe I think that uh let's say
the the order of the columns here is not
really right I can change those however
I
want okay it's
not I can reorder those I and one more
thing I can also uh remove experiments
for example I already
run dozens of experiments I don't want
to keep some of those I can just easily
click on them and then remove the
selected experiments from here one more
thing is that now I have a few
experments let's say I want to find the
one that has the best recel score I can
go there sort uh descending to find the
one that works best in this case it
seems that the best experiment is um
well and also the other one so now with
one click we can apply those changes to
the workspace so our current directory
will contain all the information that is
on this Branch including parameters code
data as well or if we are already happy
with this experiment we can create a new
Branch promote it to G commit and do a
pool request or mer request depending
whether you're using GitHub or gitl in
this case yeah let's apply this to the
work workspace and I will do some
cleaning up of the experiments so we
don't have those
here
okay I need to remove the Sorting for
that and then I can remove those okay
but actually first before I remove those
there's one more extra important thing
that I forgot to show which are the
plots so in the plots we see all all the
things that I also wanted to store
during the present uh during the run of
the exper during experimenting so the
first plot is basically the Lo the loss
function over training so here I can see
how the loss function changes as the
training proceeds it's extra useful for
uh Long training processes because this
plot is updated life as the training
proceeds then I also have the ROC curve
and the Precision Reco curve I wanted to
store the confusion matrices so I can
also uh see which model performs best or
maybe which one had more false positive
or false negatives and also the feature
important plots stored as static images
and I can of course like if I don't want
to see all the experiments I can just
remove those and compare the ones I
actually want to
see so in the interest of time I will
maybe not go fully over crit search
which I also wanted to share but I will
very briefly mention that you can use
the command line uh commands that I
mentioned before to run a queue of
experiments so you can instead of
running them as they go create a of
them few them they will pop up in the
experiments table as waiting or pending
and then using uh DBC experiment Q uh Q
start command you can what you will do
is you can start all the experiments
they will run sequentially and then you
can compare the results in the table and
of course DBC also provides some
functionalities to paral this process
and at this point you might also ask but
well this is exhausted grid search can
we do something smarter so of course we
can change the script to be a random
grid search but what we can also do is
we can use libraries such as obuna which
are integrated with DBC so we can also
track all the trials for Opa using
DC so I will now go back to the
presentation to wrap it up to also leave
some time for
questions so yes G combined with DVC
provides an efficient environment for
machine learning
experimentation with Git we version code
configurations and any small text files
such as metadata pointers with DC we
conv verion all the other artifacts this
includes data and also create
reproducible pipel
and lastly with vs code or with the vs
code extension get a user friendly
interface for experiment management and
also
visualizations so as I mentioned before
I believe the biggest advantages of this
setup are
twofold so first our experiments are
fully reproducible and second we can set
everything up in
minutes so here I releas some references
which you might want to check out
regarding the workflow I have presented
today so for example how to start
everything from scratch
and that would be all for today so
thanks a lot for listening you can find
me on LinkedIn or on medium you can also
check out my book or use the QR code to
access the repo containing the codebase
of this project and I will leave it at
that and answer any questions that might
pop
up thank you Eric that was
awesome I think we've uh got some
questions in our Q&A portion I'll uh
read them out and uh let you answer them
uh first question from Alexander there
was an example with data versioning
where we add data to DVC history is
there a way to completely remove
artifacts from history considering that
we can process real users data and we
should comply with gdr or
gdpr post the question in chat as well
yeah that's a good question I to be
honest I don't fully know so for all the
project that I worked with those were
projects that were personal projects so
I wasn't working with any gdpr compliant
data
but I do believe that there must be
functionality for removing
those right thank you and also from
Alexander he uh or they asked is it
possible to use DVC with GitHub
Enterprise yeah so you can DVC with well
any kind of git uh provider so it can be
GitHub or gitlab we can also use GitHub
actions for example to make sure that
the pipeline is triggered whenever you
commit any new code to your code base so
you can definitely integrate GitHub with
DBC
nice and then final question um that I
have oh just kidding they more coming in
um another question from uh Gabriel what
about deployment for example comparing
it with ML flow and other
Frameworks sure so DBC at least in this
scope is Mo mostly used for
experimentation but iterative which is a
company standing behind DBC they also
have a suite of different products so
they have a product used uh well for
deployment of ml models and also for the
cicd of those models so there there are
different tools in the say DVC ecosystem
or iterative ecosystem that you can use
for
those
nice all right and then another one from
Ross Coleman I'm just going to keep
coming rapid fire actually definitely
yeah next is a DVC pipelines versus
airflow versus prefect do you deploy DVC
pipelines to
p r
o uh that's definitely a very good
question so the difference between
airflow or prefect or DVC pipelines is
that those pipelines so DVC is not a
scheduling tool so this is not a tool
that I would use to actually put things
in production or run those pipel like
literally use this yaml file to run the
pipelines the reason is that they are
used for experimentation and like tools
like airflow and prefect they are used
for scheduling those tasks so they
execute in a particular day particular
frequency and so on and so on so I would
use a different tool for scheduling
those so you can of course schedule them
in the same order that they are in the
yaml file and you can use the yaml file
to build your scheduling but for the
scheduling itself I would use other
tools that are tailor made for it